[Música]
el gobierno mexicano puso fin a la
política quédate en México programa
impulsado por el ex presidente
estadounidense Donald Trump que obliga a
los solicitantes de asilo en Estados
Unidos a esperar del lado mexicano de la
frontera y que fue criticado por
organismos Defensores de Derechos
Humanos
a dos semanas de las elecciones de medio
término en Estados Unidos la aprobación
del presidente Joe biden cayó al 39%
según una encuesta de routers ipsos esto
mientras los demócratas se esfuerzan por
conservar sus mayorías legislativas el
voto anticipado ya arrancó en 35 estados
del país
y este domingo Brasil conocerá quién
será su próximo presidente Pero antes
ambos candidatos el presidente ayer
bolsonaro y el líder izquierdista Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva se medirán en el
último debate este viernes les contamos
cuáles son sus propuestas
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en francés 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
México el gobierno de Andrés Manuel
López Obrador anunció el fin de la
política Quédate de México el polémico
programa impulsado por el ex presidente
estadounidense Donald Trump dicho
programa obligaba a los solicitantes de
asilo en Estados Unidos a esperar una
respuesta en sus casos en el lado
mexicano de la frontera durante su
vigencia el programa fue criticado por
organizaciones humanitarias
termina quédate en México el programa
que retenía a migrantes en la frontera
mexicana mientras esperaban respuestas a
sus solicitud de asilo en Estados Unidos
el gobierno de México a través de la
cr-e ha venido verificando que se
otorgue la atención humanitaria
necesaria a las personas migrantes
participantes en el programa y seguirá
garantizando su adecuada Estancia y
protección en territorio nacional este
plan fue implementado por Donald Trump
su sucesor Joe biden intentó eliminarlo
pero el estado de Texas impugnó la
decisión y fue restaurado hasta junio de
2021 cuando el tribunal supremo
finalmente dio la razón a la
administración vaiden el 8 de agosto el
departamento de seguridad nacional ya
había informado que empezaba el fin de
quédate en México
cómo ha dicho el secretario mallorca si
el mpp tiene fallas endémicas impone
costos humanos sin justificables y
sustrae recursos y personal de otros
esfuerzos prioritarios para asegurar
nuestra frontera
quédate en México ha impactado en más de
75.000 personas desde 2019 la mayoría
Durante la era Trump para el comité
internacional de rescate violaba el
derecho de las personas de Buscar asilo
así vivían la espera los migrantes
llevan con mentiras con puras mentiras y
nunca avanzan
y pues deberían de ver
el esta medida se enmarca semanas
después de un acuerdo entre Estados
Unidos y México para una nueva política
migratoria los venezolanos que se han
detenidos en la frontera serán devueltos
a México y se habilitarán 24.000 visas
por vía aérea algo que podría extenderse
a otras nacionalidades de la región
a dos semanas de las elecciones de medio
término en Estados Unidos en las que se
renueva la totalidad de la cámara de
representantes y un tercio del senado
una encuesta de routers ipsus reveló que
la popularidad del presidente joeyden
cayó al 39%. Y aunque Ha logrado una
recuperación mínima en comparación con
el 36%, que registraba en mayo y junio
el bajo índice de aprobación de biden
está ayudando a impulsar la idea de que
los demócratas podrían perder sus
mayorías legislativas en el congreso
este 8 de noviembre 35 estados Ya
abrieron el voto anticipado y más de 8,2
millones de votantes y a sufragar
en Filadelfia Pensilvania el botón
disipador es solo por correo Los
votantes tenían hasta el lunes para
inscribirse el 15% de ellos se registró
para enviar su voto por correspondencia
entre ellos este hombre que acaba de
votar vine a este buzón aquí frente al
ayuntamiento siento que es el lugar más
seguro para poner su voto
las autoridades pusieron en marcha
sistemas de seguridad para tranquilizar
a los votantes
estos buzones están vigilados 24 horas
al día por una cámara y las imágenes se
almacenan por lo que podemos verlas
incluso después del día de las
elecciones las papeletas se recogen a
diario para que no permanezcan allí
durante días
en otros estados como aquí en Texas el
botón principal también se realizan las
oficinas como si fuera el Día de las
elecciones el procedimiento es Antiguo
se remonta al siglo 19 en un principio
estaba destinado a facilitar a los
habitantes de zonas Rurales remotas o a
los soldados durante la Guerra de
sucesión en Georgia uno de los estados
más disputados en estas elecciones la
votación comenzó el viernes aquí el
principal temor es la abstención
queremos que comprendan el poder que
tienen y que pueden cambiar el resultado
de estas elecciones
Así que sí solo queremos explicarles lo
que está en juego con su papeleta y
esperar que se registren y vengan a
votar
a dos semanas de las elecciones más de 8
millones de estadounidenses ya votaron
en dos tercios de los estados en los que
está abierto el botón anticipado un
récord y una posible señal de que la
participación va a ser alta para unas
elecciones muy ajustadas quienes también
irán a las urnas son los brasileños este
domingo 30 de octubre decidirán si
mantienen en el cargo el presidente Jair
bolsonaro o si traen de vuelta al
expresidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
el viernes ambos candidatos se medirán
en un último debate y se espera que
durante esta cara a cara se pongan sobre
la mesa dos planes de gobierno muy
diferentes de dos figuras muy
contrapuestas tanto por sus orígenes
como por sus valores y posturas
políticas
son rivales políticos y algunos expertos
los han llegado a catalogar de Némesis
lucinacio Lula da Silva de origen
humilde se convirtió en obrero
metalúrgico y sindicalista en Sao Paulo
mientras que bolsonaron nació en El
Dorado rodeado de áreas de preservación
indígena donde comenzó a idolatrar al
ejército y el uso de las armas Sin armas
el gobierno quiere que esas personas de
bien no tengan Paz en la calle y tampoco
en sus casas Lula emergió en el mundo de
la política como líder sindical junto al
partido de los trabajadores desde su
fundación defendiendo la justicia social
y el bienestar de los más pobres se va a
enriquecer a los ricos y empobrecer a
los pobres aún más tras su carrera
militar bolsonaro saltó a la política
como diputado federal pero siguió
defendiendo los valores militares con
muchos represores de la dictadura
militar como ídolos por el ejército de
las cajas por nuestras fuerzas armadas
por Brasil por encima de todo y por Dios
por encima de todos hacemos en lo
ambiental bolso la concesión de reservas
indígenas y amplió los permisos para
explotar la amazonía ya tenemos más del
14% de nuestro territorio nacional de
marcado como tierras indígenas
pretendían que mi gobierno llegara el
20%, eso invalidaría nuestra economía
en cambio de Luna ha ido acercándose a
temas como el ambiental o los derechos
de los indígenas con el paso del tiempo
que han tenido un fuerte peso en la
campaña de este 2022
respetaremos la amazonía nuestro bosque
sin embargo hay zonas grises en las que
los dos candidatos no son tan diferentes
en especial respecto a la religión en el
centro de la campaña en el país laico
algo que ha empujado a Lula regular en
posturas progresistas llegando a decir
que estaba personalmente contra el
aborto la vida es el mayor Don que nos
ha dado Dios
y bolsonaro ha mantenido su discurso en
contra del aborto de la ideología de
género y a favor de la familia
tradicional una elección entre la l de
Lula o la l a favor de las armas del
bolsonarismo
el paso de la onda Tropical número 46
por Venezuela dejó grandes afectaciones
en tres estados del país incluida la
capital donde el martes se registraron
lluvias torrenciales y vientos
huracanados que obligaron a más de 160
personas a abandonar sus viviendas en un
barrio Popular de Caracas allí los
vecinos denuncian que las malas
condiciones del terreno ocasionaron un
deslizamiento de tierra que causó el
colapso de 12 viviendas
Caracas hace evaluación de daños el paso
de la onda Tropical 46 trajo intensas
lluvias con descargas eléctricas y
ráfagas de viento el martes a la capital
venezolana las autoridades iniciaron el
balance de los perjuicios ocasionados se
realiza evaluación de daños y análisis
de necesidades no se reportan personas
lesionadas la acción preventiva permitió
la evacuación de más de 50 familias en
situación de vulnerabilidad antes de las
precipitaciones y el riesgo de
deslizamientos pese a la presencia
Estatal los vecinos de la ladera un
barrio popular caraqueño denuncian la
mala planificación urbanística en el
sector que ya había sido víctima
anteriormente de otros derrumbes hay
casas que mandaron a desocupar y con el
transcurrido del tiempo pues volvieron a
habitar remodelaron reconstruyeron y se
siguieron habitando 12 años después se
ven las consecuencias de esas decisiones
los deslizamientos de tierra causaron
además el desbordamiento de varias
quebradas que inundaron vías arrastraron
vehículos y cortaron las comunicaciones
terrestres
verdad que
mayorró bastante pues con la cuestión de
que me dicen que se había asustado
porque prácticamente ella nunca ha visto
esto y nosotros Bueno si lo hemos visto
pero a verlo en carne propia No no es
distinto a que te lo cuenten a otras
personas pues las afectaciones en
Caracas se sumaron a las de otros 13
estados incluidas las de aragua en el
centro del país donde el pasado 17 de
octubre las intensas lluvias dejaron más
de 50 personas fallecidas en Perú las
autoridades electorales recurrieron a un
particular juego para definir un empate
por la alcaldía del distrito de corcuya
en el sur del país miren esto es el
momento en el que un funcionario de la
oficina Nacional de procesos electorales
lanza al aire una moneda para decidir a
cara o sello Quién será el ganador de
los comicios la suerte favoreció al
candidato Alfredo baldarrago castillo
del partido izquierdista Perú libre
de esta manera despedimos este
Informativo en frases 24 Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]